I don't believe Elon is a right winger
and when you see interviews with him
um certainly at least socially and in
many ways culturally seems very moderate
or even somewhat on the left in my
experience so I don't think it's elon's
a right winger I don't that's not an
interesting critique it does seem though
that throughout the Twitter Escapade he
certainly ended up closer
to some voices that may be influencing
him in a particular way uh that's giving
some people that impression you know but
as far as like the Elon hate or the Elon
love it's just it's just a person who's
done some interesting things some of
which I like and some of which I could
kind of leave leave aside I have seen uh
folks
be drift towards the right more
in response to just the viciousness of
attacks from the left like who I well
Elon and so so you just you do think
he's drifted towards the right uh
in uh so I don't think at the core but I
think on the surface okay I think uh and
I think Joe Rogan has as well on the
surface because I think maybe you can
correct me but it feels like people on
the left attack more viciously
um that has not been my experience well
oh it hasn't no this so so yeah let me
know because my sense was that they
attacked people on the left viciously as
well left a textile it's its own because
you're not Progressive enough you're not
uh you know it's just this kind of
bullying that happens very intensely no
you're a hundred percent right that when
the left
has attacked me
um it's almost as vicious as when the
right attacks me the difference in my
experience is
it's a smaller contingent on the left
that's willing to Levy those attacks
against me but I'm on the left so to
some degree you could say well that
that's to be expected
um there is toxicity on the left but
it's intense isn't it like that's what I
mean like the attacks on people who are
on the left just uh you're not left
enough yeah that's no that's the and it
is a small number of people I can't deny
that that is absolutely uh absolutely a
a real phenomenon and
um it depending on what sort of topics
you take on publicly you are going to
suffer the wrath of that to a greater or
or lesser degree but with all of these
things what I always go back to is you
know I probably would have more
disagreements with Rogan today than the
last time I was on his show which was
like at the beginning of the pandemic
but there would be zero and I've done
Clips critical of things that he has
said substantive of course to me it's
sort of like oh yeah I could sit down
with him and do a podcast and it would
be zero big deal and I would tell him I
stand by everything I said about what
you said and I would say it to you right
now there are people who write to me and
go oh man things must be really really
tense now if you were to Rogan would
never have you on because you disagreed
and he loves you I'm sure he's just not
thinking of you know I'm not the most
important thing to Joe Rogan I think
both of us would be able to sit down and
talk about every one of my criticisms it
would not be taken personally and then
we would move on and it would be the
next day